hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast
and just checking in on
you uh first things first I was giving
away some last week on the uh on
Monday's podcast it's been giv away the
uh the practice guitar the the travel
guitar and the uh flight simulator
software so thank you to everybody
that asked we just P we just the most
desperate looking
[Music]
[Laughter]
people it's the holiday
season um anyway I have more I need
to give away so you know I got a bunch
of I got to give I got a
bunch of books I want to give away I
always want to walk down the street you
know those little things those
uh those little nerdy uh cupboards on
the side of the road or whatever you
call them little glass thing leave a
book take a book take a book leave a
book that type type of thing for like I
don't know who the last thinkers amongst
us I'm sure it doesn't happen out there
in the middle of
Kansas right it's too goddamn spread out
maybe in Kansas City not not not not way
out
there you know places I used to go to I
can never remember all the the far out
places far out man places I went in
Kansas just in Nebraska like
hay Hayes Kansas I remember driving the
80 in the middle of nowhere and for some
dumb reason it was like this wooden
bridge that went over I'm like what in
the it was just like a field on
either side of it like at least that's
how I remember it um and then like Grand
Junction way out in
Colorado all of those places anyway you
know we only need one book out here
that's how to cook math no the Bible the
good book um whatever I'm I'm I got to
get I'm going to get rid of all of this
I got so much
like I'm in in my my drum room
right now it's just just clut look at
all these drums look at all
these what I what I got what am I a
session drummer or some you know
what this is It's when you don't have
the gift of music what you start to do
is buy all the that your Heroes
played and you're like maybe if I play
what they play I'll be as good as they
are and it just doesn't work and then
you have your own little music store
here your own little music store old
Billy freckles old Billy
Whiskers I am uh s days in no cigars no
coffee I'm telling you right now it's
not going to last all right if I can't
have a cup of coffee I I could maybe do
without
coffee but and the cigar thing you know
I don't know I don't know how to do it I
don't I'm I'm I'm an all and nothing guy
I'm either doing
it or I'm not I don't know how to
uh I don't know how to lay off
you know what the key is to laying off
is actually laying
off that's what I don't
do I do it and then the next day in the
next three days two three days when I
should just lay off and get that craving
out of my system I don't I give into it
I need to lay off but I was doing great
like this time last year I I I went
November December all the way to like
May of last year where I was I would
take the first 10 days off no vices no
nothing all right no heroin no
who is no
nothing um no my vices are basically uh
weed gummies I I go in and out with
those things but I I just don't like
them I'm not a weed guy I'm a booze guy
and I left the booze behind I celebrated
five
years five years of uh smoking more
cigars and drinking coffee instead of
you know killing myself that way instead
of the alcohol now I'm going to get a
bunch of WebMD douchebags going
you know actually you'd be better off if
you still drinking because you know the
new study show you know you know my
favorite thing in the it wasn't
my favorite thing but I just like to
preface things that I say I either say
you know what my favorite thing is or I
say 90% that's my percentile percentage
that I like to use and whatnot but um
what I was going to say is uh these
I like these people that somehow
they know how to find the truth on the
Internet is the most amazing skill you
could ever
have like the level of lying on all
levels of the
internet everybody just spin in their
all of social media for for the
most part
right I saw this I told you I saw this
stupid ad of this guy he was
wearing the lining of a
jacket okay and they just said hey hey
hey this is the new style wearing the
lining of a
jacket you be like I'm not doing
that I'll just unzip the lining of my
winter coat no they don't do that they
having a muscle
car making this guy seem like he's just
everything from here to
Grand Junction
Colorado banging all that stinky puss up
there near
gy is it the slaughterhouse or is it the
women we're taking callers I'm sorry
that was me
um you see you know I only only social
media I do is
Instagram all right and I just watch
drummers and I look at old cars and uh I
try to stay away from those those
um those those people that are showing
you how to work out who is um it's like
what they just none never have any
clothes on and you just try as a
man not to click on it and the second
you click on one you watch one
video the next time you go in you hit
the magnifying glass it's like that's
all there
is you know so then I got to watch like
19 videos on a Buick Century or
some just to try to with it
again you know to get it
back okay I made one mistake
Instagram
um I don't even know what I'm talking
about I'm just I'm I'm talking about the
lies
man
um anyway I uh uh I flew again this week
man I'm getting this is the time of year
where they have the Santa Ana winds and
every time I go out there I'm looking at
the sky and the sky is nice and clear so
I'm like well it's got to be pretty
windy up there and sure enough cuz I
didn't I didn't redo my windy app but
even if it's really is windy I got the
fully articulated mainroad system I you
people know this I've told you this
I'll just fly the pattern cuz it's not
good for the heli did be sitting around
right so um I get in it's n you
know winds
variable right which doesn't mean like
which way they coming from it means they
they not even registering as far as I
can tell you know let's say five knots
when they say wind's variable it's just
just calm a little little little uh a
little whisper this way or that way
right so of course I get in there I
listen to the AIS and all said I hear
like you know some notam about
turbulence I was like I knew it
so I go up anyway you know I'm dumb
right I'm not dumb I'm safe I like I'm
going to go up I'll fly the pattern if
it seemes like I'm getting knocked
around I'll come back so I went out and
I flew I don't know I flew about
like me maybe about 20 minutes in one
direction I started going up and over
the hills and then of course that's when
it starts getting all bumpy and I was
just like I don't need this do I
need this I don't need this
and I just went back set it down
perfectly perfectly I got the muscle
memory back right as you bring it onto
the pad you just sort of drive it on on
staying just ahead of your own
vortices and right as you're about ready
to set down gentle a cyclic and it just
sets down like a daisy I set it down
like that when uh I gave my
wife uh the r oh she took a little video
of it oh that's right oh am I patting
myself on the back I think I am anyway
plowing ahead people let's enjoy the
rest of this year we don't have a lot of
it okay after today we only have 31 days
left 31 days left until it's another
ungod L year of a presidential
election Jesus
Christ is there a reason why our our our
only two picks are going to be two guys
like that are like 85
years
old you know that's all I want at this
point I don't give a what color the
tie is I just want somebody in their 40s
that's going to have to live with some
of their
decisions oh my God I just
realized I'd be you know if somebody in
their 40s gets in I've never been older
than a standing
president I've never been older than a
president they've all been older than me
I think the youngest guy right now would
be uh Barack
Obama OB right he's probably the
youngest guy but once you know once he
went in there that's the thing the
second you get in there you you
you start looking like a Founding Father
how quickly you age even Barack Obama
you know they say black don't crack it
goes gray though I'll tell you
that he aged like they all
did um Bill Clinton went snow
white absolutely it did um why the
anybody would want that
job just stay in the Senate you're still
going to be worth 20 grand with all the
inside of trading that they're
not allowed to prosecute you on
and no most people don't even know your
name so even if they get mad in your
state you just move one state over
nobody knows who the you are and
then just tell them ah you know I bought
Apple
stock that's it that's it and then
you're up in New Hampshire you got your
indoor outdoor infinity pool
into a mountain of coke that you
skate you ski on that's how you do
politics you don't get into politics to
help people if you get into politics to
help people that's how you get whacked
all right well you got to help the right
people right you got to help the right
you got to help the right ones baby
uhhuh
um get my ass kicked this bed
MGM
I'm so sick of the half a
point it's
genius it's genius that's right
up there with 22 is a push in
blackjack for the dealer and the dealer
only how what happens when I hit 22 oh
you lose I mean isn't there enough here
you got two decks going I can't count
cards it's it's not enough it's not
enough you just got to get some
more H you just got to get more out of
me don't
you like a goddamn broad
um I have a great week as a dad
Jesus
Christ my uh one of my kids wants
something for Christmas and I'm
just like you you're not you're not get
we're not buying that you know and uh
you know kids kids don't get a when
you tell them no they they just they
just you know they act like an adult
woman is what they
[Laughter]
do they just go get really emotional
they say crazy and you just have to
sit there and take it going they don't
mean any of this just ride it out just
ride out the storm and that's
kind of like what I do you know if you
notice about this podcast I don't have a
GU guest I talk about people they're not
on here they can't defend themselves so
I always end up being the hero okay and
this is done on purpose I'm building my
brand oh speaking of which on
Monday December 4th I will be announcing
my
2024 2024 tour I cannot believe
it I started way back in 1992 Jesus
Christ and now it's 20 24 I had a buddy
of mine just found some footage of an
interview he did with
me way back in the day I think it was
like he he thinks it's around
2002 and I remember right around then I
started to feel like I was becoming a
grizzled vet and I was only 10 years in
and it's funny now 32 years in to look
at look at me back then with my
thin face still had a full head of hair
and I was just looking oh my God I was a
I was a baby but I still think I was
like 34 though if it was 2002 but
whatever I'm going to take a look at
that footage and um I'll be posting on
one of these stupid Throwback
Thursdays or uh I don't know I'll use it
for something I'll use it for something
um but anyway the the presidential
election is coming oh my God can you
like what are they going to do they
can't have Joe Biden
debate he's he's not going to know where
he is there's no way there's no
way that that guy can make
it to November next
year what's the over under on
that huh sunglasses sunglasses and a
half one and a half aviators
that that guy's going to be able to make
it I don't know what they're doing with
that guy it's like can you just let the
guy I mean I'm
55 I need to take afternoon naps unless
I pump myself full of
coffee old freckles I I got to go lay
down I don't I don't I don't got time
for that I'm in my Danny Glover
years I'm too old for that and this
guy 80 years old it's kind of
ironic you know he probably wanted that
job his whole life and he finally gets
it he's not even going to
remember
it I don't
know they should treat him like a horse
that broke its
leg I mean have some
you know have some d i i i don't even
know anything that's going on I just
know what people have told me evidently
he told me that we have the money to
go to war
again and somebody should have spend oh
yeah Joe how do you know how the do
you how the would you know I know
you're supposed to make fun of somebody
that has like mental problems but it's
like you're you're allegedly running the
company the country here sorry the
company
um I don't know I did a uh I did a fun
show yesterday I did a wasn't a
nooner I did a 2:30 in the afternoon
show for uh for some cops out here in La
um which is such a fun group to do it in
front of because they're like this
they're like cowboys and conservative
all at the same time it's like they're
wide open and they can be like oddly
conservative so like I was sort of like
when I was doing the uh the show like I
would say you know most people laughing
but there was a few people looking at me
and I was thinking like I don't think I
want to get pulled over by that
person but the rest of them were cool um
this really cool
spot um and a bunch of motorcycles there
and so that's another like I'm
another you know Guitar Center dad with
drums I'm also that way with like
motorcycles I always look at them and I
talk to the person that owns it and I
say you know I wrode a couple of times
uh you know I used to play in a band and
you know that type of thing or like I'm
the funny guy at the office all the dumb
that you say you know when you meet
somebody that's doing something that
that that you wish you were doing you
somehow got to be like you know I threw
a football once I guess I can talk to
you now that you're a professional
quarterback um anyway some Michigan fans
were upset this week huh that they
weren't number
one I don't even give a that
they're coming at him for that
sign stealing I just want to
know who they pissed off cuz that's
that's the thing with that you
piss somebody off and they decided to
enforce a rule that they just don't
enforce I think everything has that it's
kind of like what they're doing with
Trump right now right it's just like
they could enforce that rule on
every Rich out there forget about
the bankers who give them the loans you
know who just allowed them to inflate
you know how much their their asset was
worth versus what they were going to
loaned out right you could do that to
anybody but old Donnie
boy the orange he pissed them
off um and what's funny is these morons
that like him thinks that he pissed him
off cuz he was going to clean up the
swamp that's what I love that's another
genius thing that he did literally being
in the swamp and then acting
like he he was going to I'm going to
clean it up it's like aren't you the
swamp I'm confused right so this
guy
um I just this is my theory on that guy
they don't give a
about whether you're president
whether you have a blue tie or a red tie
they just want to know what you're going
to do they just need it to be
predictable I think I've said this
probably a million times in this he was
just un nobody knew what the he was
going to do and then he turned on his
own cabinet and like all right this
guy's out of his mind okay I
don't mind a Larry liberal in
there I know he's going to tax the
out of me me so I can move my money over
here but I know what he's going to do
right talk about stealing signs right
they know what the they're going to
do but you get you get Donnie in there
old Crazy Legs Johnson you know he goes
up there you know they call the play in
his helmet and he starts doing a
audible like like pton Manning they
don't know what's going on and the best
part he doesn't know what's going on all
he knows is he just called the greatest
play ever some people would say that
maybe he's the greatest play caller of
all time I don't
know I want to try that on my
wife when she gives me I actually
did something today and she she goes to
me she was telling me how proud she was
of me she goes you know 85% of the time
you drive me nuts I go 85 she goes yeah
she goes but 15% of the
time 15% of the time you're great right
which is really a fair assessment but I
blew them the moment I could have gone
Trump on
her you know I should have just been
like you know what actually I'm an
incredible husband I actually don't
think that you have the ability to
understand how great a husband I am I
mean some people might say that some
people are saying that I'm the greatest
husband of all time I mean I don't
know um still watching Cojack still W
not watching the news that's what I'm
doing but I if I'm going to put together
a new hour here well I don't know I
haven't taped a special yet right I'm
just getting sick of my sick of you
Bill um I did have a good week of
Christmas shopping though you
know I was sort of flatlined I didn't
know what to do and
uh I actually got my daughter her big
gift and my son's big gift is on the
way and now I got to deal with my wife
hey I got to deal with my wife I got to
I got to keep her in line
here I don't know what I'm going to get
her I have an idea I think I know when
I'm going to get her I just have to go
do it and then I did this
spontaneous purchase for my daughter and
I got the wrong size and I I
thought I was being so
smart these cute little purple pajamas
you know she likes purple this week you
know last week it was blue before that
it was red you know you know how they
are
right by the time Christmas comes along
she's probably going to hate purple and
I I bought her the size that she is now
and I thought I was being so smart cuz I
got it gift wrapped so I don't have to
deal with that and now I got to
take it back to the store get it ungi
wraptor and get back there before the
other ones are gone it's just like this
is just so it's and I'm the whole time
I'm just sitting there go this is so
stupid I went to one of these
big box stores okay and I got my son
something and then I spontaneously
bought my daughter something I end up
getting the wrong size so I have
to go back I bu both of them gift
wrapped and then I go downstairs and I
say hey I go do you got a face
scrub for
men I used to use that Clinique but
they changed their for formula it sucks
now now it feels like lotion I like it
when it feels like I got an SOS pad on
my skin it makes me feel like I'm doing
something here I mean what am I I live
in LA there's all kinds of smog I got to
get it off my face I mean this this this
is the bread winner okay my big
Charlie Brown head um so of course what
she suggests only comes in this big
box with like these three other
goddamn things it's like I don't want
all that I just want the tube of that
and she goes it only comes in this thing
so I go all right how much is that she's
like it's
$75 I'm like for those three tubes and
she's like yeah she goes but it's on
sale for
63 and I'm like all right and then she
Rings it up and goes okay that'll be $70
it's like what happened to
63 juy 75 and it's on sale for 63
that'll be $70 that's what she did I
just started
laughing like like is that like a
Abbott and Castello bit bit that
you just did so anyway so of course I
get this and I set the box down you
know right when I walk in and it's just
been sitting there for three days and
I'm like I'm never going to use that
um but I
tried um so anyway I'm I'm going to try
to um try to get my Christmas
done
um maybe like in the next week if I
could just get all that done and then
have all of my
wrapped um then I can just hang
out cuz I really don't have anything to
do everything is kind of behind me thank
you to everybody that's been watching
Leo by the way getting a bunch of nice
emails about that
um Adam
Sandler
um playing Lee Leo and all of that types
Robert Smigel I'm trying to remember all
the names people that I worked with
bunch of geniuses over there wrote a
killer script
I got to do a couple of lines in it you
know once again once again that's been
my formula that's my formula I do 10
lines in something amazing that somebody
else wrote and then somehow they think
that I'm a part of
it
oh oh I just gave you the code that's
how it is that's how it is 10 lines
five lines on Chapel show 10
lines on Breaking Bad couple of scenes
on Mandalorian I'm not writing any of
that stuff I didn't come up with that
none of that's my I just went in
and said what they told me to
say you have such an interesting career
yeah I wait for other people to write
great and then I say what they
wrote and I did it again with
Leo um so thank you to everybody over
there and thank you for all you guys for
watching the um so anyway there's
some sort of stomach virus going
around with all the damn
kids uh
um my kids have been all right so far
but I'm just waiting for that to hit
that should come in that should come in
right around Christmas that's
what I'm
thinking that's how that usually
works but anyways as I mentioned uh
earlier that I was off the cigars and
coffee I'm going back to the
gym you know I still haven't gotten I
can get into the green shirt that was
the goal by the end of the year so I
only got four more weeks and I only need
to lose about like three four more
pounds which I can do if I buckle down
but the problem is it's the month of
December you know so there's all these
Christmas parties and so uh
I'm just going to make sure I go easy at
those you know I'm just going to have
like a
uh I don't know try to have a healthy
meal before I go to those things do a
couple of laps say hello to people and
then get the out of there I mean
I'm at the point right now I'm laying
off
bread oh red is laying off off the
bread unbelievably difficult I had no
idea how much bread fills you
up you know you have have a meal after
with no bread you ever just eat healthy
like 20 minutes later you're hungry
because your body's just like all right
we processed all this we've converted it
to energy and now we need some more
you know we're running low
here you turn your body into like a
gaser right we have just enough fuel to
do the quarter mile whatever the hell
they did that little gas tank on
the front of the
thing then you eat like a
sandwich and like just how I guess how
hard it is for your body to process I
guess shitty bread you know I think if
you have like good bread or whatever the
Italians do that semolina instead of
whatever the we use over here
um yeah I don't know this American food
that that you eat you that is
the good thing about our poisonous food
is you stay full for a while but but um
I'm trying to be like I know this isn't
going to last everybody okay so don't
roll your eyes at me I'm already
doing it all right I'm just trying to go
as long as I can with
uh this whole
um this whole Health thing that I'm
going to be doing I know I'm done with
cigars for a while though but um for a
while means probably until the end of
next month I mean what am I supposed to
do here
like what am I supposed to be like
meditating and taking naps
and eating
salads did I me tell you what this
douche said he's not my doctor anymore I
went into the guy right he does
a check out checkup right and rather
than just saying like hey man you're in
great shape at 55 he was telling me the
stuff you know I got to watch out for it
so I appreciated that and he I go oh
really I got to watch out for that he
said yeah he goes at your age there's no
good
news can you believe you said
that I I so many times I wish I could go
back to that moment and just be like uh
can I have my chart please you're no
long of my
doctor like what the kind of thing
is that to say to a p obviously I know
that I know that I'm sliding down the
back half but I also know that your
mindset is what is is really important
to your health why would you just say
the most negative thing
ever I just felt like that was like such
a ego thing for him to say you
know there's no good news d d all right
there doct smok and
feffer huh what you got you got a little
lab coat and all of a sudden you a
couple of pens you think you know
go
yourself Jesus
Christ sitting there looking at
a half naked 55-year-old bald Ginger and
you come up with the brilliant there's
no good news after this there was no
good news when I was born I was
orange I weighed 10 pounds I was
a
mess
but Ginger was a watermelon
that's what I look like there's not one
cute picture of me a baby I've been
hiding the behind the eightball
my whole goddamn life I don't need you
coming in
here I'm sitting on this piece
of paper for 10 minutes so you
can make your goddamn dramatic
entrance Jesus Christ there's no good
new oh at 55 do I start growing hair on
top of my head again oh I thought that
that's what happened oh thanks for
clearing it
up jerk off he should have been
a veterinarian you know I always love
about veterinarians are walking around
like they're actually doctors too it's
like you're not all right you're a
professional
farmer you're a white collar
[Laughter]
farmer oh the only reason why that made
me laugh so hard is cuz it didn't really
make sense and then I was also pictur
ing veterinarians listening to this and
getting super
offended uh no I like veterinarians I
can tell you what I'm done watching ugly
chicks hugging cows though on Instagram
Jesus Christ it's it's like how which
which one's the cow you know I'm so sick
of people trying to tell me that
they understand
animals oh they have the same emotions
we do oh do they do they really or are
you are you just not connecting with
other human beings so now you're lost in
this weird world I mean when you
love an animal to that level you like
you ever see those weirdos that are like
they're literally in love with their car
and it goes beyond just being a car guy
like they actually get aroused looking
at it like I saw this thing one
time on one of those trashy shows and
they were showing people that are the
women that were in they were in love
with inanimate objects like there was
something wrong with them I
think animal people you know this if I
like I love animals hey I like him like
the next guy but I'm not going to lie to
you I do go on YouTube and I
watch him battle to the
death I do watch that I did watch a
bear trying to pull a pig over
this the side of this fence and
he couldn't do it you know what kills me
about prey is they don't help each other
out you know what I mean like if you
went up to a lion let's just say
you could him up the other Lions
ain't gonna sit there and let you do
that they're gonna jump you hyenas do it
all the preed wild
dogs car spaniels they don't got to
throw them in there they bite more
people than
junkies car spaniels bite more
mail men a year than junkies bite police
officers I'm going to put that out out
there I'm I'm going to say that I think
that's a
fact um I learned that when I owned a
pitbull and you know the only people who
said that people that own pit
bulls trying to pass the guilt onto
somebody else um sorry my chair sitting
in this chair that's a little little
squeaky here um no I I'm not going to
lie to you I would love to go hug a cow
all right I Like
Cows you know actually I have to end on
that I Like Cows there you go you know I
like the whole deal I like the milk I
like hearing them moo I like petting
them on the head I like when they're
slaughtered and then you eat
them with some greens um all right
that's it that's podcast everybody uh
enjoy your weekend you and uh then
there'll be a bonus episode of the
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday Morning podcast all right see
you hey what's going on it's Bill Burr
and this is the Monday Morning podcast
for
Monday November 30th 2015 what's going
on how are
you um I'm not doing it's Sunday
night sitting here with my
pitbull and I'm watching uh it's
halftime of the Patriots Broncos that's
when I'm that's when I'm recording
this you know what sucks about the
NFL I never thought I would say
this this parody thing I swear
to God every any team can beat any team
so you die like a thousand deaths every
Sunday remember back in the day you know
if your team was good you had those
teams you could just kick the out
of four of them a year it just seems
every week now you're in a dog
fight it's 14 to7 now they're going into
the half it's starting to snow out there
these orange crush are starting to
feel
confident high tower got
hurt now what are you going to do hey
you know what I noticed watching Sunday
Night Football you know when they have
the uh the little thing I'm sorry I got
the TV on in the background I can't
believe they're redoing the
whiz you know do you guys ever see the
original one I I swear to God is it me
or is it 9 hours long it takes
them like 3 hours before they even get
to nipy
Russell come on in he's on down why
don't you run down the road I'm
sorry that's such a bad joke but it's
too
long um who the pitch to redo that
thing I don't even get why do you put it
out now that's not a holiday
movie why don't they just keep them like
the old ones do you know I'm I'm taping
Rudolph the redns
Rudolph the red nose reindeer that
classic
one from
um what whatever back in the day
I'm going to watch it you know Tuesday
night it comes on get myself into the
holiday spirit I can't have the
TV on do a podcast cuz I'm just keep
talking about you guys want to watch TV
with me I just saw this new Rota um
Jennifer Lopez movie or TV show I don't
know what it was that was just coming
out I thought it was going to be one of
those commercials where Rota just stares
at somebody cuz they're not drinking
vodka I just want the other person to be
like Frank no I mean I'm sorry I love
good Fellas but this is my
drink what's going on with you man
what's what's with the looks
relax I get it you can kick the out
of
me you
know he's just laughing at their
manhood he's disgusted with them he's
disgusted it's actually an amazing piece
of acting cuz he never says anything he
just looks at him and you just
see you just see the generational Gap
you can just see him going your entire
generation is a bunch of
just with one he just gives
him that one look and next to
you know of course they got the guy
sitting over there with like an umbrella
drink I don't think I've ever sat in a
bar and anybody's ever looked at
me because what I was drinking I guess
I've gotten for it you know but
that was just back when I lived in the
Boston area oh come on you Mary
do a
shot um oh I'm driving too we're all
driving you don't hear us making
excuses um anyway so you know when that
that horrific Sunday night
football song comes on you know the
little CutiePie there in her glitter
outfit cuz she's in chiz right so you
got to have some glitter on it's all
this special effect um I don't know
if it's me or what is isn't that song
just a complete ripoff of Joan
Jets I hate myself for loving
you when they get to the whole
you know I I love myself for watching
football isn't that how it goes I think
I don't know what they say I always fast
forward through it I've never liked that
song I I liked it back when it was an
orchestra you know when you had somebody
like John Williams you had some great
composer come up with a piece of music
that could actually move you emotionally
and then somewhere along the line they
went to Hank Williams
Jr and he took his hit song all my rowdy
friends are coming over
tonight you
know don't blame Hank Wings Jr it's not
his fault okay his dad obviously banged
somebody who had no musical Talent
whatsoever and so the best Hank Williams
Jr could ever be is half Hank Williams
Senior but you know sometimes you get a
little more you
know you get a little more one than the
other so rather than him singing what
the did Hank Williams
sing you're cheating hard my lonesome
truck I I don't know what the he's
saying but all I know is that guy like
drank himself to death but he was only
like w I gotta look this up how
old was that guy that guy looks like
he's
60 he drank himself to death but wait
wait wait wait I got to look this up I'm
sorry I'm sorry you know this is the
kind of this is what happens this is
what happens when you just run
your goddamn mouth Hank
Williams Hank Williams Hank that he was
he was the original Frank the tank but
he was Hank 1923 to 1953 he was
30 years
old you know he that's a you know as as
sad as that is that is a hell of an
accomplishment to drink yourself to
death by 30
I mean anybody can ow D I mean that you
know but I mean to literally to put in
the hours that the the amount of
hours that it takes to drink yourself to
death in only 30 years I mean you got to
figure the guy didn't have his first
shot of
booze we say I'll even give I'll say
13 he had his first drink of
booze and within 17 years guy's
dead that's amazing I remember a long
time ago watching some show or
something it was saying the body was
actually designed to live 150 years
optimal conditions you know basically if
they treated you like a classic
car that' been had a body off
restoration they just sort of floated
you around and never drove you or
anything like that right like you could
live you know breathing perfect air
eating perfectly and all that you'd live
for 15 years um which that made sense to
me because every time when those people
used to come and give the cancer talks
about cigarettes and be like every time
you smoke a cigarette You Take 5 minutes
off of your life there's 20 cigarettes
in a in a pack so that's a why that's
minutes so you just took almost two
hours of your life away so I was sitting
there you know doing my dumb math going
well Jesus Christ you'd be dead
by the time you're 30 cuz I was counting
down from like 80 I guess they're
counting down from
150 or maybe they're just lying and
they're trying to scare the out of
you and they don't think some freckled
the crowd's going to try to
actually do some math I don't know all
I'm
saying is you got to give it up to Hank
Williams you
know drinking himself to death you know
ah you know the first third the first
third of therosis is fun after a
while it's not fun anymore but you know
a lot of things aren't fun after a while
you
know being a parent isn't Fun after a
while you see it on their faces once
they get past the little bundle of joy
once he's done saying cute things once
they're done being
cute you know like they step on an ant
and they say hey hey look look I deaded
it i d like oh did you say I she just
said I deaded it rather than I killed it
oh that's adorable right the little
things kids
say once they get past that and they
start rolling their eyes at you
you know you're just like I'm I'm
over this
that's right parenting is like
sorosis of the
liver look at Bob cus with his
smart looking coat and his goddamn scarf
guy always looks sharp you got to give
it up to him um am I the only person who
winced when they talked about what was
wrong with pton Manning's foot planter
fisheri is which I've actually had um
from improper technique playing drums I
didn't know how to get I was trying to
do those John botom triplet
things from Good Times bad times and I
think I was just using my big toe to try
to make it happen so I was arching my
foot and I don't know what the
happened I woke up the next day I
thought someone was stabbing me in the
foot but
uh Payton actually it's basically this I
don't even know what it is I had it I
don't even know what the it is I
thought it was a
tendon that runs along the arch of your
foot I don't know what after I saw the
drawing then I didn't know what the
it was but it goes from your
heel to like uh like where you get your
bunion there you know if you get hammer
toes stop hammer toes if you get hammer
toes right that part that sticks out
anyways the part near the heel they say
is tearing away from the
bone what the
I'm done I am done at that
point I like part of my body is tearing
away from the
bone I'd stop doing standup if my
arm from leaning on the mic
stand is something in my elbow started
tearing that I would just be a podcaster
that would be it my voice would crack
and I would
cry so it looks like we're going to be
losing pton Manning and Kobe Bryant in
the same year two Monsters of
their game you guys see Kobe's poem my
wife read it to me actually even as a
Celtics fan I was a little sad then I
also had to chuckle that he wrote this
whole poem this whole OD to basketball
and then not once did he ever mention
coaches or teammates and I was kind of
thinking like you know what that's why
he never passed the ball did
he
he's still one of the greats but Jesus
Christ how about a shout out to
Shaq at least his ass you know remember
that how does my ass taste I'm sorry let
let's let's get let's get back let's get
back on track here what was I talking
about I was talking about planter
fisheri is that no I was talking about
how I'm the the hook of that Thursday
night song the Sunday Night
Football song they got to get you into
it right cuz you're not in because
you're not into football evidently so
they got to have some lady come out a
little sparkly dress throw a couple
looks to the camera like you know what
I'd blow you if you were here I'd
blow you she got to give you
those looks Thursday Night Football is
here's my tits right they do that can't
break free of the things that you do
it's the same song the full life
of me you know I think Joan Jed ought to
she ought to go after the NFL
why not they went after Tom
Brady why can't they go after
Joan Jet do you know I got in a big
argument with this friend of
mine right who right now I think he's a
no I don't but he just was you know
he was being a he was being a what I've
never run into a whiny giant fan New
York Giant fan I love giant fans they
never they never whine they just
beat my team I got to respect
that he was he was still whining
about the Giants losing to the Patriots
two weeks ago it's like dude you went 2
and0 in the Super Bowls against
us why do you give a about a game
in November he was no who won that game
we actually won that game cuz when the
guy caught the ball they said they
wasn't a catch but he caught it yeah I
agree with you I thought Dez Bryant
caught that ball I don't
understand what you got to do
these days for them to call it a catch
it's a weird rule so he started
going in on how the Patriots cheat and
all that whiny horeshit and he
tried to say that the Patriots went this
is the best one I've heard so far the
Patriots win 90% of coin
tosses which I you know that's the
number I always pull out of my ass when
I want to win an argument that's the
percentage I always go with
90% look 90% of people out there with fa
blah blah blah right so he tried
to tell me that 90% of the time
we win the coin toss it's like okay so
what are we doing
there are we somehow sneaking a
different quarter in there like it's
it's just un and he continued on with
the whole the Patriots watch the Rams
final uh walk through before the
Super Bowl even though ESPN detracted it
and said that was a complete horeshit
lie of course they detracted it at 12:30
in the morning you know they talked
about it for 5 years at 9:00 in the
morning on Sports Center and then when
they find out that they were
perpetuating a lie they then oh oh sorry
about that at
12:30 so
um I don't know I finally got him to
come around I finally got him to come
around it's just like look okay if you
want to say they're guilty of
gamesmanship absolutely do they
you know try to get away with if
they can get away with it yeah but so
does everybody they just don't
win all the Super
Bowls you
know it's unfuckin believable what other
teams have done and there's like no
problem like I'll tell you right
now that do you guys see that
that Redskins play where uh uh Kurt
Cousins they hiked the ball and the ball
flew out of his hands and he he
asked the ref where did you get this
ball CU he thought there was something
slick on it and they go you got it from
your own sideline if that happened
during a Patriots game and the other
quarterback said that we would have lost
the draft pick somehow they would have
but is it is it possible that
maybe they they greased the they
had somebody sneak over dressed like a
and greased up the
balls
um you know what I mean I don't I I've
gone through this a zillion
times but uh you
know I I I don't it's unbelievable that
that piece of Jim ERS and that
piece of uh I can't
remember his
name man Eric
manini have effectively tarred and
feathered the the Patriots that we that
will be brought up for them for the rest
of Time air pressure and
stealing signs is what they're
guilty of right that's
[Music]
it these other teams half their
defense tested positive for steroids
they're building stadiums that make
their fan base sound loud it's
hilar Ah that's they're pumping
crowd noise in Ah that's fine
it's fine don't worry about it don't
worry about
it Jesus Christ we still signs
for one game one game it was
illegal and then all that's all all they
did it they they did it every
game
unreal I'll have to have that debate for
the rest of time it was only illegal for
that one game that we did it and got
caught if we did it the year before the
year before it wasn't illegal
and all you stupid out there who
think all you have to do is just film
the other coach and then you know what
they're going to do you dumb you
got to you'd have to take that and line
it up with their plays watch it at
halftime and then try to memorize as
much as you can if you're lucky maybe on
two plays you know what the they're
doing you know what I
mean I mean the teams sit there and they
they watch game film every week
looking at their formations and all of
that how is that
legal you couldn't do that back in the
30s
right just sitting there I guess
you could if you get what camera some
guy into those jockey pants and
just sit there rolling the film how is
watching game film legal that's you're
considered then you're a good student
but if you try to steal their signs then
you're a I I I don't get it I don't
get it but I'm never going to defend
that the Patriots don't try to
bend the rules in their favor but I
won't go so far as to say that everybody
else in the league doesn't also
do it this whole horse you know
what they sound like they sound like
Republicans when they talk about America
when they go America was founded
on everybody's got a shot and they
completely ignor genocide and slavery
right that's what other football fans
sound like to me when they when they try
to act like we're the only ones who
dick around with the
rules oh Jesus Christ he just landed on
Brady the Brady rule in effect personal
foul hitting Tom
Brady I love that man he's got a cute
little butt 15 yards first down I love
it I love it I love that's called the
Brady rule you know even it's the it's
the money rule they call it the Brady
rule that actually suggests that the NFL
on some
level gives a
about uh Tom Brady they don't they
give a about the money he makes you
know what I mean it's like Lance
Armstrong all right after all the
after he gets caught
everybody gets on their high horse
that's disgusting that's not what the
Tor to France is about and all that
let me ask you this all
those that made all of that
money when he made when he won
seven in a row and people who didn't
give a about bike racing tuned in
and watched and they could charge more
money for
advertising okay during that whole time
did they give the money back all the
money they made all those owners
that made all that money off all those
guys doing
steroids you know hitting the ball over
the goddamn freeway made all
that money oh we going to clean up the
game oh yeah you're going to give away
all that dirty money you made you
like you didn't know they
were doing
roids that's your team if you managed an
Applebees and and half of your staff was
on steroids you you wouldn't you
wouldn't
notice at some point when you walk in
when you're going in to go get a fresh
sack of potatoes you wouldn't
walk in on somebody injecting somebody
else in the
buttocks just out of just being there
every day you know what was
going on I ever tell you that time when
I used to work at that
uh it's holding all day and they
let it go Brady deep there's an
interception it drops the ball lell you
we got a away withholding
on that
one Jesus Christ anyways I used to work
in this um I used to work in
this restaurant it was called the Sable
Cafe in carry North
Carolina back in like
8788 ah why did I just say that now I'm
going to say all this horrific
about it was a fun job and uh there
was some uh activity that were going on
in the back room I that giv a it
was almost 30 years ago anyway so I
worked in this place and
um I used to work on a mosquite grill
and I had this big chef hat like I knew
what the I was doing and uh the
place was gradually going out of
business one of the managers had a major
cocaine program but a lot of people did
it was the 80s it wasn't really it was
just becoming a problem you know that's
right around was cocaine the big lie you
know what I mean so this guy used to
steal from the register he do a little
toot right and you know you know
if the the the guy if the guy
running
is on drugs and I mean it just
trickles Dam guy sent the example so you
know I remember you I used to work like
the dinner shift one night and
it's this fancy restaurant and
by fancy I mean there's carpeting
there's cloth napkins and they had a
giant fish tank all right that was fancy
for Carrie North Carolina you
know those always
giving me for being a Yankee you
know in fact Carrie back then stood for
concentrated area of relocated Yankees
that's what they used to say like you
know you know you know what Carrie
stands for you know what that stands for
uh no budy what does it say it stands
for concentrated area relocated yane I
hate the draw play you has
the draw play ever it's never
worked the draw play okay it must have
worked at some point they keep running
the thing I think that that's
when you've just decided that you're
going to
punt and be like all right you know what
let's just not give the ball over right
here let's just uh you know just wait a
second it
never it never
works it's weird how the draw play
doesn't work but somebody
basically doing the same thing but if
they go out for a pass it always works
or it works more times than not you know
what I mean like sort of the the uh
delayed
screen right
when you got the line Gap backers coming
up the a gap ah Jesus Christ what are we
doing ah
Christ anyways I gota be honest with you
uh with all the injuries we got I think
if we were play Carolina Panthers right
now um the only reason we if we would
win would' be we would just out coach
them out of experience but I
think Carolina looks like uh they look
like World beaters to me
um I don't know how up is it that
the Redskins are f five and six
and they're in first
place you know what I mean like I think
seven and nine could win that
division you know I'll tell you what's
going to be brutal is watching the New
York media drive Tom Coughlin out of
town that's going to be unreal
like he doesn't know how to coach you
know it's not his problem that one of
his best defensive
players maimed
himself you know what I mean that whole
thing he had to deal with I mean
I don't
know I I don't I mean the guy's
a winner man he he came to BC
immediately turned it around after the
the the the Doug fluty hangover all of a
sudden we became we were winners again
right after bck Nell left he went to
Jacksonville he almost got the
Jacksonville Jaguars to the
Super Bowl he goes to the
goddamn New York
Giants they win two Super Bowls beating
the undefeated Patriots
18-0 guy has one bad I guarantee
you they're going to they're
going to send him out of town
is you know one of my buddies thinks
it's because of his windburned face I've
never seen a guy who needs
lotion more in my life like I think that
that's his next move before if he gets
run out of town you know and he just
needs a break from
football they should do that thing you
know like if you going bald and they
just go not only the uh
douchebag in the commercial I'm also a
client right he should do that with like
uh whatever face lotion whatever the
you call whatever how how do you
get get that red off of his he's
got he's unbeliev the guy he's has wind
bur in like September it's
like it's like he he always looks like
he just got done competing in like
America's Cup you know what I mean at
least come out with a little noxema in
your nose right I know what you guys are
thinking like Bill you're just running
your Yap here how about a break
I haven't gotten the advertising or the
the questions yet for this week
so I'm just filibuster in here
trying to get through this um
hey did I uh did I mention that I went
oh I told you guys on Thursday I went to
the uh the Kings Blackhawks game and
um what what if the highest level hockey
I've seen in so long it was Unreal like
the whole first period it just seemed
like they were feeling each other out to
see what they were going to do and
and just the whole thing every
line every defensive unit their
the way that they play do you know there
was there was only two penalties the
whole there was two penalties in the
first period that was it um Chicago went
up two nothing and then the king scored
two in the third and then came back uh
and won in overtime by the way three on
three even if you hate hockey
there's there's nothing to hate about
three on threee hockey in overtime it's
unbelievable just endtoend
action every 5 Seconds it seemed like
you were seing a two-on-one or a
breakaway and um oh the lovely Nia
everybody look at you lingering over
there I actually heard Al Michaels
tonight talk about the three on three
hockey are you leaving yeah are you
going to come here you going to go see
Creed yeah Nia's like one of the only
black people ever into that
band no yeah don't you like them what
did they sing about
Jesus cries on the BR and and he got
stabbing aside again no not not Creed
the band what did Creed s read the movie
I don't know if you can sing a Creed
song I'll take you out for an ice cream
okay can you take me
high oh that's
right that wasn't bad can you take
where I don't know what he says
[Applause]
yeah is that like power rock is that
considered power rock those kind of
bands where like the lead singer is just
like like just like this really time
they say
power associated with music there's no
power in it okay come here come here
says who says you yeah it justs me in my
dumb
opinion oh you are over me today
are they playing in Boston the Patriots
no they're playing in Denver it always
rains look snow sorry um yes I'm going
to go see Creed are you coming are you
going to be done uh I don't have the
advertising of the question yet so no
look at
Cleo look how cute she is she's actually
exhausted but I took her on a long hike
today yeah I think we definitely need to
start feeding her more cuz you exercise
her like serious like an athlete yeah
because she didn't put on 10 lbs
I did yeah me
too you know what I'm going to try to do
in December what's that honey oh God I
pissed Nia off today I got to tell the
story I got this thing Nia oh God Nia
hates when I I make fart noises like if
I'm singing and I don't know I just go
if I just do that I hate when people do
that in general it's so I don't like it
cuz I don't like bathroom toilet humor
like I just I think it's so gross so she
hates it so of course what am I going to
do so I'm singing along to the radio and
I just keep making fart noises and the
matter she gets the funnier it is to me
and I keep thinking don't do this cuz we
had a wonderful afternoon this is going
to ruin it and I just it was so much fun
I had to keep doing it yeah and you kept
doing it while acknowleding that you
were irritating
me I have to go to
movies you know there's something wrong
with you if you don't think of farts
noise is funny I can see if I actually
farted and you had to deal with the
death that came out of me right no
nothing is wrong with me you have the
maturity of a 12-year-old and it's like
you can't just let someone enjoy their
day without doing something irritating
it's true you like to irritate people
especially me admit it admit it I have
no idea what you're talking about I just
wanted to take my lovely wife out to
lunch you did take M lunch it was very
nice it was
great okay
goodbye I don't want to stay away such a
problem with that I'll you know what I I
will make an effort to stop doing it can
you take me
higher 47y old person has to say I'll
make an effort not to make fart noises
like what seriously I'm a clown
that's what I do for a living what do
you want from me not to make fart noises
you're better than that bill I'll
you with your reverse psychology I'm not
I know how much you hate that saying
you're better than
that it's
horrific um all right I'm going hey have
you noticed the Broncos quarterback is
like 8 ft
tall are you talking to me yeah why
would I
okay why well you can notice if
somebody's tall can is that weird how
tall he is I don't know which
one you're referring
to they all I want to see him riding a
tank like Michael dakus just to see how
much of his torso comes out of that
hole remember when he did that
oh you were too young when they when he
ran for president he was running for
president he was doing fine and then he
drove a tank well he didn't drive a tank
they just had him stick his head
out I remember when he was running I
remember when he was running for even
though I was young and I remember his
wife drank like rubbing alcohol didn't
she kitty kitty oh yeah kitty duus yeah
top three dumbest reasons I ever saw
anybody not be able to run for president
or lose it is dakus sticking his head
out that
manhole that's what it looked like it
was his it was his eyebrows
that's that's what Screwed
[Laughter]
Gary Hart getting in trouble for
banging his uh that broad on the
boat I mean that's what you get a boat
for
right all right you're losing me I'm
losing you and then third was when
Howard Dean
went and theny was just like all right
that guy he got a little excited he
was like a wrestler weird I thought that
was weird we're going to go to Carolina
we're going to go to Mississippi we're
going to go
to yeah he was s all right I'm leaving
goodbye it was an
unfortunate it was an unfortunate
moment hey and enjoy the movie I wish I
was going to go see it well you know
what time it is I text you all the
information do you mean literally what
time it is are you saying that in like a
black way like you know what time it is
oh Jesus she hates
me um all right that's the first half of
the podcast I have to wait for the
advertising and all that so it's
not goingon to mean to you I'm just
going to hit pause and when I come back
I'm going to read a little bit of
advertising uh it's 14 to7 the 9- foot
quarterback drops back he throws it down
and that's a first down for the
Broncos Jesus Christ look at the size of
him there's not even any snow on the top
of his helmet I mean guy he's above the
storm
clouds
sorry what's his name
Osweiler
do you know Nia took me to this
German bar and I had the best goddamn
BRS and I got one of those giant
beer steins like a
um but whatever it it starts
tomorrow man I got to turn this
around I actually I didn't lose the way
nice
play um I didn't sorry I didn't uh I
didn't lose the way that I wanted to
lose but I just I stayed the same which
is pretty good for Thanksgiving
week I still worked out every day but
you know I made a bunch of pies I had to
eat them you know what the was I
supposed to do so
um anyways what I want to do is uh six
days a week I'm actually going to go to
the gym and I'm going to get on that
elliptical for an hour I'm going
to do it six days a week throughout
December that's the promise that I'm
making to myself and as you can tell by
the tone of my voice I'm not even
remotely thrilled by it but I refuse to
go right back to to the fat ass
weight that I was uh the
pies are done most of our Thanksgiving
food is done so I can go back to my
uh my thrilling way of eating
healthy I can't believe I oh
what the I can't believe I did this to
myself again you know what the one good
thing I do have is I haven't had a cigar
in 15 days that's pretty good so I want
to be that guy who you know once
or twice a month I'll Have a Cigar it'll
be a special moment you know I
mean oh God I just pictured Caitlyn
Jenner in a bubble bath my wife showed
me that picture and I freaked
out I wasn't ready for it you know just
showed it I was just oh and he missed
the field goal Yes
W there you go yeah with your stupid
movember
mustache we know people are dying of
cancer you shave that
off um
anyways I'm just literally stalling
waiting for this to come in
here all right I got to uh let me let me
hit pause here I'm going to hit pause
and I'm going to find out where
where where every I'm going to get to
the bottom of this and uh when I come
back you guys are going to get to listen
to me read out loud all
right all right by the
magic with the magic of the pause button
I'm back like a half hour
later still 14 to s the beginning of the
fourth quarter but now it's time for me
to read out loud with that
Mees and I am out of oh for
sakes tackle the guy Jesus
Christ oh God damn it this
parody well I know we got a lot of
injuries and but Jesus Christ this
parody is killing
me they're killing me Whitey they're
killing me so the other night I went to
a bar surprise surprise after um after
the uh the Kings Blackhawks
game um I took the subway back I love
taking the subway out here you know what
I mean and it's like a real subway now
like there's all kinds of
vandalism on it and I remember when
you know when I first moved out here in
2007 you went down there it was just
like you went on that Subway and it's
like wow this is
what the world would look like if there
was like a massive plague yeah yeah let
him turn the corner and get a first down
and a touchdown there you go great
defense guys way to
go Christ sake um anyways I was
thinking like this is must be what the
world's going to be like after a giant
plague hits right and then we start all
over again then we still know how to do
right we still have some reason the
scientists
survive somehow the scientists
survive that would be the ultimate thing
if the scientist survive so you
like you had the same amount of people
on the
planet that um
that
existed you know when we were just
running around in caves and
um but you have all that that new
technology then that that would be
perfect right yeah you need ditch
diggers too who going to plow the
street and pave the roads come on miss
the extra point you cun 21 to
14 um am I the only Patriots fan that
actually think it's a good thing to
um to maybe lose a game and go into the
playoffs and let the pants be
undefeated Oh They'll they'll always I'm
just thinking you know get a little less
attention just one year i' would love to
be treated like the Indianapolis Cults
you know what I mean where your owner
can literally be abusing drugs and
around with everyone you know
and nobody gives a
it' be tremendous just liveing that
quiet time out there wouldn't that be
nice well I think it would be you know I
I think it' be nice if I could get some
questions over here I don't know
what else I'm supposed to do with myself
well what am I up to here 45
minutes of me running my Yap and trying
to read out loud this is getting
ridiculous you guys want to listen to me
send a text this is pathetic you know
I'm going to start my Christmas
shopping oh I know what I was going to
tell you so I came back on the I
know I'm all over the place you
it's how my brain works so I'm on the
Subway I get off and uh I meet
Jay lawhead at this bar and it's
just one of these cool bars that
not a lot of people know about but
enough people know about that it stays
open you could chill out in
there man you can have a good time and
it was perfect it was a perfect old man
bar I apologize for yawning if
I'm making you tired at work
um and everything's going good and then
out of
nowhere this cool bar they start having
karaoke and all these nerds are
going up there and just going just going
full out singing horrific singing
dancing just absolutely
awful just a a an horrible display of
communication was going on and it was
annoying the out of me cuz I just
wanted to be in a quiet
place drinking why am I yawning all over
the place drinking a you know a
beer or something I just want to be a
nice quiet place right and
um the
halfway through them singing and
dancing everything I actually
tap laad
and I go I go look at him look at him
lawhead look at him I go that's what's
heckling you on Twitter right
now look at them trying to dance look at
these animals trying to sing
look at
them these are the PE these are the
people that
blog these are the people that get
offended oh look at Collins W then M
Michaels both rocking the scarves I
never understand why they have the scar
are they are they inside or are they
outside they always make them look like
they they got the window
open do I need to take a nap what the
just happened you know what it is
I'm getting sleepy waiting for these
reads to come over here um you
know I'm interviewing P Corelli this
week uh for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday Morning podcast
where I check in on you and uh he has a
new special out on Showtime I believe
this is one of my favorite Comics that
uh not enough people know
about um great Storyteller and I've
known him I've known this guy for 20
years uh back when we used to um
work the New York comedy club together
late night spots and all that who the
is that guy Brady keeps throwing
to the anti-g grun who is that
guy oh and we get a pass interference ah
Here Comes our first loss of the Year oh
well what the you gonna do anyways
um you know what I'm going to H pause
again I'm GNA wait for these things I
swear to God this is this is the most
up Podcast I've ever done I'm GNA
wait for these these I'm coming back
reading people going to prepare you
right now all right I'll be back well
you know the technology I'll be back in
a second all
right all right I'm back I I don't know
if uh that's probably weird that I say
all right I'm back cuz it didn't seem
like I left with the editing
right shut up Bill we get it you hit
pause
um I can't find I I don't my reads
aren't coming through this week so I'm
just going to pick some out
here as I go from old emails somebody
sent me something something uh because I
mentioned that I went to Chipotle and
they had all these signs on the wall
about how hey we don't put any in
our food which made me weird it
out like well you shouldn't but I guess
so many people do I don't know so I
thought you know made them seem Shady to
me right by the way it's 217 at this
point in my
world oh for sakes you got to
catch
that it's behind him though um
anyways yeah it says hey Bill just want
to drop your line about Chipotle which
you mentioned on Thursday's podcast uh
check out this recent article in the LA
Times Chipotle is being harassed by a
bogus consumer Watchdog group that is
actually funded by restaurant Alcohol
Tobacco and energy companies they are
spending millions of dollars harassing
companies that do or say anything which
goes against the interest of their
clients Chipotle's stance against
antibiotics and meat has apparently
incurred their
wrath uh this firm is engaged in a very
public ad campaign smearing Chipotle so
I think proba this think this probably
has something to do with all the signs
you saw in Chipotle the other day
touting their product and what they do
differently thanks for the podcast go
yourself so I I clicked on the link
there and
um and it says uh why is a nonprofit
shill for business interest attacking
Chipotle says the US Department of
Health and Humane Human
Services says that if you're being
pushed around by a bully walk away and
stay away don't fight back Chipotle has
taken this message to Heart evidently
they're not fighting these guys Chris
Arnold a spokesman for the burrito chain
told me Chipotle has no plans to tangle
with the food industry front group that
has run a series of ads critical of the
company's Health
claims uh the guy says Chris says this
is a smear campaign but we've chosen to
take the high road position the most
recent ad appeared last week in the New
York Post it said Chipotle is scaring
the public and tricking people into
thinking the chains meat is healthy
because it's quote antibiotic
free blah blah blah blah so allegedly
this is just some this is a group that's
pretending to be a watch drug group but
it's actually you know a spokesman for
probably corporations that put
antibiotics in their food
um and all of this other Jesus Tom
Brady is just acting like a
lunatic when are they going to throw a
flag on the guy I know he's got
seniority but even as a Patriots
fan what is yeah he's he's you know he's
flipping
out yeah he's losing his cool look at
like Tommy Tommy get the out of
here okay you're the face of the goddamn
leag uh we we we can't give you a
grank seems frustrated oh and
the Broncos cheating God that's all
right that's okay are they are they
doing little underhanded things
to get an advantage that's okay you're
in Denver it's fine it's fine no
cheating no underhanded there Tom
Brady throw deep down the what
the
oh boy this doesn't seem like it's
our night now does it
217 now it's 4th and 15 I don't like it
I'm already drinking I already got I
already got a beer here so anyways uh
these guys I guess
um I don't understand how these groups
are legal I guess they've been around
for years where you can put together a
fake group like Rick bur executive
director of the center acknowledged that
the organization is funded by part by
food and Beverages
Company um he declined to name any of
the contributors and he and the guy goes
it doesn't matter who pays as long as
what I'm saying is truthful and I'm
telling the truth what a Croc of um
you know what I guess who knows I don't
I don't know what to believe now I guess
now I'll go to
Chipotle I don't know I I what
is that a belief I mean now if you're
going to have you know what I
don't understand this genetically
altered salmon now like why like why
weren't we allowed to vote on that why
don't they put that to the people why is
that the Senate oh that's right
cuz they got them all paid off right is
that how it
works Jesus Christ do I have to hit
pause again I do I got to find another
leather this is like uh this is
like what podcasting in the 1800s must
have been like been like
right I got a bad feeling we're going to
lose this
game why Bill did the Patriots help you
pay your bills no but I mean you
know they're the football team of my
city be back in a
minute all right so I guess there's
going to be no reads this week I I don't
know what to tell you I don't
know where the they are but I'm not
waiting around all night all right
there's four minutes left we hand off
the ball and they tackle us
again right at the line of
scrimmage
um somebody my drum teacher got me into
Tears for Fears this week I couldn't
stand them in the 80s I just hated the
guy's face you know I hated the way he
sort of launched his face at the
camera as he sang welcome to my
world it's
the
RO nothing ever
that right and I just couldn't get past
their
face so first down so he uh
um three and a half minutes left come on
Patriots hang in there get a
field goal over there um that still
wouldn't help us why I feel go put up up
by seven points I like it so
anyways um he goes listen to this uh
Tears for Fears I was like I I was like
oh my God tears for fear every Everybody
Wants to Rule the World and for you know
how many times I've heard that
song like now I don't mind Tears for
Fears cuz it reminds me of the ' 80s
when I was young had a full head of hair
my whole life in front of me you
know you know my pants were all puffy I
was lifting weights every day but only
the upper
body the way you're supposed to oh no
the grunk just get hurt he took it oh no
oh no oh no no oh
no oh
dude everybody who's even remotely
good on the team is hurt
now except Brady I shouldn't have just
said that
oh Jesus oh they just went to commercial
just went black ah anyways um so he
says listen to this Tears for Fears you
know everybody wants to rule the world
no might get the you know so I'm
listening to it for years I never heard
what was going on with the high head you
know the guy's playing triplets but he's
he's playing them in groups of two he
accents every other
one listen to it I always say just don't
don't don't I thought it was that I
didn't know like the high was going g g
g g g g g g g g right only drummers
understand what I'm talking about right
want
and it's kind of like uh the way when
you first learn how to jerk off like you
know you just
try it's the same thing except
you do it on the high head but anyways
here's the point of the story that maybe
you guys can relate to this most
up Podcast um that I've done is he then
played this song about the ladies it's
some song about women set them
free and quit around with them
or whatever the hell it is where is it I
downloaded the song but this's this sick
ass
Phil towards the end of the song and uh
my drum teacher showed it to me you know
goes over the bar line comes out on the
and of one it's unreal and who
is it who is it on drums Phil
Collins and I go you got to be kiding me
people on my podcast are on
Phil Collins talking about you know how
he sucks this oh look at grank he down
oh this is bad they keep saying how
he sucks and all that you know and he
was going you go what are you talking
about this guy's a monster every
other he did in uh was it Brand
X oh no he got hit right in the
knee
um all of that type of stuff
um oh God that's bad
guys I'm sorry I'm watching I'll never
do this again this is like
ridiculous that I'm doing this at the
same time um but anyways I'm covering my
eyes cuz I don't want to see his
leg knee wiggle like that
again this is this is why people hate
Phil
cohs all
right it's because they don't take the
time to act like this is a guy he's such
a talent that he
actually like he could go to Berkeley
played drums I mean I know he's had
health problems but at the height of his
popularity he um at the height of his
skills I should say before he got hurt
like that guy could before his
hell I'm looking a
grunk before his health got up
I'm sorry guys this guy would
have like like musicians at Berkeley
with their jaws on the ground
all right and they're into all his prag
Rock but then he was so good he
could actually write songs that
made 14-year-old girls dance around like
Molly Ringwald in Breakfast Club and the
problem is is your average
jackass classy Bronco fans clapping
right there Class Act Right There the
your average jackass isn't going
to listen to the to the Prague Rock
stuff so all they're going to listen to
is cudio and all that I remember in the
80s I hated Phil Collins mid 80s
I couldn't stand the guy and then when I
started playing drums and I started
paying attention to who was drumming on
what I was like wow I mean this guy
drummed on the tears for fear things he
drum for this is in the 80s Robert
Plant Eric
Clapton uh when Zeppelin got together he
played with
them um if he really sucked I don't
think that they would be bringing this
guy along would you so I would say
listen to uh some of his oldest
that's all I'm saying I you know what
I'm going to put a clip Up of him just
playing uh just playing drums and people
probably still say that he sucks but I I
I think he's the uh but anyways um
can I bail now guys can I just say that
that's the podcast I'm sorry I didn't
have the materials I needed but
I got a uh I got an early day tomorrow
I'm starting to get ready I'm hyping the
fers for family by the way uh getting
great feedback on that and uh I just
wish it would come out already and uh we
got a Premiere coming up out here in La
which I'm really uh excited and nervous
about um there's this weird
feeling when you watch something that
you did and it's it's being shown on a
screen and you can't fix it and it's
just going to be played it freaks me the
out because I'm used to performing
live and if it's going shitty I can
speed up I can slow down this this I can
make at least try to make some
adjustments but like if you're in
something and it's not working with the
crowd you just got to sit there and
write it out and
um you know it's a it's a helpless
feeling so I'm excited about that night
but I'm also nervous but I'm going to be
coming back East to do some uh to do
some press and then I come out here and
I do a few more and then I go to the
premiere but uh once again it comes out
December
18th uh also as I mentioned thank you to
everybody who went and bought Felicia
Collins new uh Blues album off of
iTunes uh what else did I want to help
oh The Great stocking stuffer for
2015 his tickets to the uh the fourth
annual Patrice O'Neal Comedy benefit um
that's going to be going down Tuesday
January
26 did I say going down I think I did
you know why cuz I was trying to focus
on what I was saying here and not the
fact that we just had to punt the
ball away again um makes a great
gift it's obviously in remembrance of um
one of the great friends I ever had in
life and
uh I was talking to his mom the other
day and it reminded me of
uh it's a Patrice O'Neal story
he called me up one time right
this is back when we were both still
living at home with our
parents and I pick up the phone he's
like Bill he goes what are you doing I
was like I'm not doing anything he goes
uh let's go up to the uh the Square One
Mall and I'm like all right where's that
and he's like it's up near sagus up near
the uh the
cowon and
um I go all right why the we I go
what do we have to go up there for it he
goes well you know they they I I need to
get a
mop I go you need to get a mop he goes
yeah and granted this mall is
like there's like three malls between
where Patrice lived and where I lived
and he wants to go all the way out of
his way to go up to this goddamn
mall and I'm like what the kind of
Mall what kind of mop do they have at
the Square One Mall and he's like uh he
goes one of them Square One M mops
and he starts flipping out
on me
so I go all right I just finally got it
out of him he wanted to go up there cuz
it was right when they first put cheese
in the crust a pizza and he
wanted to try it
[Music]
out and he started laughing when I
finally get it out he goes I got to try
it I got to see what it's all
about so we drove up in the middle of
the day sitting in traffic on
Route One to buy a mop and so he
could try stuff crust
I don't know why I told you that I'm
just I'm trying to fill up the
hour here have I done an hour is it
mercifully over see you guys saw my
cryptonite right here man if I don't
if I don't have any questions
what do I do for that last half an hour
I have no idea you know what I realize
is how few people email me and give a
everything on there was just
about uh it was either
spam or it was about uh efforts for
family one or the other you got to do
this you got to do that or uh it's just
a bunch of hhip but I I I thought I
could scroll through a couple pages I
could find some I guess cuz you guys
sent them to the other email and I don't
even know how to get to it oh is that
what you think Bill all right that's
been the Monday Morning podcast this is
a completely up one I
apologize uh profusely for this awful
free podcast all right before you guys
start blogging about it and you tell me
that you're
offended
um anyways hey if anybody sees that
movie Creed let me know if it's good or
not cuz I actually want to see that uh
on two levels one uh I'm a big fan of
Sylvester Salone and two uh I need to
get back in shape so I figure whoever's
playing you know Stallone's Always In
Shape even at 70 70 he's still
in shape oh how about the Bruins
by the way went in five in a row is that
what happened I think they did all right
that's the podcast go yourselves uh
P Cory Elli this Thursday and thank you
once again to uh Joe Rogan for getting
me on The Joe Rogan Experience help me
uh promote the uh effers for family uh I
really appreciate it all right go
yourselves we talk to you next
[Music]
week what's up everybody and welcome
back to the anything better podcast show
NFL Edition preview for week number 13
Lucky 13 Dan Marino 13 who else
Bill oh as far as he's the best 13 I
ever saw uh who's a good 13 there Alex
Rodriguez Alex Rodriguez was 13 in
baseball there's got to be another 13 in
football no oh well Odell Beckham Jr's
rookie Odell Beckham Jr was 13 um trying
to think who else it's a college number
it's a college number more I think than
a right for like everyday players
superstitious I don't know Paul I
talking about
him uh anyway guys uh first before we
get into our picks today before we get
into the NFL we got to shout out our
sponsor it's the BET MGM sponsor the
best lines the latest lines the moving
lines this week all right guys here's
how it works all you have to do is
download the BET MGM Sportsbook app okay
and use our code bonus code Burr buur R
doesn't get easier and put as little uh
put a deposit at least $10 in place your
first wager and receive up to $1,500
back in bonus bets even if the BET loses
okay so uh all you got to do if the BET
does lose your bonus bets will be
available once your initial wager is
settled so there you go guys that's a
great promo use code bur B RR and there
you go download the app and it's all
good uh this is week number 13 which
means um bill has the first pick this
week uh we've both been status quo we've
both been we've all the line is going
here man I don't know there's been no no
ups there's no Downs it's been a weird
week I'll tell you I can't I can't be
three in one to save my life I'm two-
two every week this week though I went I
went one two and one ah you only lose
half because whatever reason
back in the day for and I used to think
why the don't they why do they kick
that extra point once you've won an
overtime once you score a touchdown and
it's over but they always did they
always did until I had money on the
game um and they didn't kick it they
would always kick it I thought the best
game of the week though man that game
was dude I was at no empathy no empathy
for me getting on that extra
point no I mean of course there's some
empathy it's it's I didn't feel it uh I
was at a party uh my daughter did a
friends giving so Sophia did a friends
giving but this year the family said
they want all of the family and parents
to come so we go to this house it's nice
and they're DieHard Eagle fans the dudes
from Pennsylvania great guy great dad
and he literally said he goes guys I'm
be honest H with you if uh if this was a
playoff game you guys wouldn't be here I
we I just started laughing he goes but
it's a big game so he goes with the
game's gonna be on we're gonna be
watching the game you know if that's a
problem I don't know what to tell you
I'm gonna be running around going nuts
and not he wasn't though he was joking
about that but he was just watching and
his kids and he has this little daughter
and she would run in younger than Sophia
and Lucas and she'd run in after every
good Eagles thing and just high five
them and stuff like the whole family was
in on it and it was awesome but what a
game dude and pretty nuts to think that
the bills
done um yeah I mean I don't know dude
that that whole that whole thing this
year like the whole AFC East just went
out the window yeah like the whole thing
was just going to
be the bills in the Jets with Aaron
roders right now Aaron Rogers is
starting to practice practice but I mean
it's too late for the Jets but I'm just
saying maybe there'll be a little bit of
exciting and then the Dolphins I don't
know I I I don't not I'm not buying
those guys I know that they've been
doing well but everybody in our division
in the bed did you see that
idiot trashing Tom Brady going he played
in an easy
division and it's just like yeah when he
did he play an easy Playoff round did he
play an easy Super Bowls how many and
the guy had like no rings but it's
probably why he did it he was like you
know I'm gonna have a hot take yeah when
he said that and he said to the two and
then he goes no offense to Teddy brusi
and Randy Moss and then he looks at Rex
Ryan he goes oh and you too I guess all
three of you he go that's the weakest
AFC East Division and I was just like
whoa and Teddy brusi Randy Moss
took it as a joke Randy Moss just
smirked and they were just going like
what the f Rex Ryan took it the hardest
who's the guy who said it Alex
Smith Alex Smith I mean what did he ever
do Alex Smith yeah first round pick with
the who was this uh
49ers so he's never done and then
he went to the Chiefs yeah so that's
kind of like something that like a
sports writer would do where he doesn't
have to prove himself s on the field so
that guy went out on the field and
didn't win anything and then he's going
to trash this guy that's he's just
trying to he's just trying to be that
guy there's no way he thinks that
dude how about this going into week one
everybody had I know I thought these
teams had a chance bills gone Bengals
Joe burrow gone jets with Aaron roggers
gone it's been a it's been a pretty
wild you're right the AFC is taking hit
and I agree with your te he by the way
for that guy saying we had an
easy schedule every year for whatever
reason we always had to play this
Steelers and we had to play the Colts
they weren't even on a Division just had
to have Brady versus pton Manning Brady
versus uh uh rothberger can I say
something I don't believe in that I
don't believe in easy schedule everybody
oh you're playing the Texans it's an
easy schedule then they got a rookie
it's nothing too they used to said the
they're Patriots are a boring team
they're winning with a bunch of nobody
you can't win you know what it is Paul
this is intelligence is not just
reading smart or knowing a bunch of
numbers and stuff it's how you process
information and that right there is a
classic example of someone who isn't
smart now the smartest sports fans are
the ones that aren't screaming at the
television that's what I've learned well
I I I I that I'm a dummy but I know that
Paul let's get into this man I got a I
got a oh I got a big day today all right
let's go you get the first pick this
week bud what a bright time it's isn't
it great when you when you when you're
stressing to get your kid the
gift and then you finally get the big
gift I knocked one of those out
yesterday my wife I don't know what else
to get her um hey my wife I'll
tell you it's a rough one um I'm going
with the Lions going down into New
Orleans um you know they the bed
last week I'm I'm sure that their coach
gave them a nice inspirational like we
did all this work to blow it
November and then just we're gonna do
this to Lion fans again I don't know
what's going on with the Saints I think
they're down there you know trying to
put the pieces together I I I have no
idea what's going on down there I just
know you know people are always partying
I think half the team's drunk Paul I'm
going with the Lions minus four going
into New Orleans Mercedes Benz that is
probably the best pick on the board and
if I would be that's I jumped all over
because I knew you were going to be like
a good team having a bad week and then
you say at home but I I knew you
couldn't lay off on the road that's a
great pick Bill all right well did you
just have a snowball fight can you
explain to the uh listeners why you are
dressed like you're gonna go Build a
Snowman okay I will
um okay I will my my daughter's sick my
wife is sick I started to feel like I'm
getting the chills my basement is
freezing and my ears were hurting and I
said you know what it I'm not yeah
I'm not trying to be were hurting or
they were cold no I was getting like a
little bit of an earache I'm getting a
little congested so I said you know what
why not just I got one for you Paul what
get yourself some raw ginger I got some
ginger advice here from a ginger Oh I
thought you were gonna go with the every
every uh every advice people go here's
what you got to do you got to get black
tea everybody no I'll tell you I'll tell
no I got one that actually it
didn't it nothing cures the cold but
I'll tell you it keeps it out of your
throat raw ginger it sucks cut like an
inch of it off peel it and then just
eat it and swallow it roat's
gonna be on the fire okay on the fire
it's G to be on fire then a spoonful of
that raw
honey got that that kind of eases that
and then some uh some lemon water yeah
activates the whole thing I'm telling
you all right I'll try was coming
on I was like all right here's some
tape and onion to your foot old
wives I think I think uh you know a
lot of what you need is in your fridge
not at CVS yeah there goes those
advertis you got to take a cup of rice
and put it in Jin sing and sniff it for
15 minutes it's a life flavor all right
no but there's actually there there are
things out there of course no ra G
that's the one I can't too raw garlic I
mean Jesus I'd rather drink
Dro um all right you got Paul with my
first
pick since that pick was the Epic pick
off the board I'm gonna
say I
mean I mean
dude it's tough this week sucks Paul
this is a tough week this week's like me
it
sucks
um I can't believe I'm going to do this
but I'm goingon to do this I'm I'm going
to take Sneaky Pete and the Seattle
Seahawks I love that pick getting nine
getting nine and I think he's a way
better Coach than uh Wayne font whatever
that guy is who's who's there
over there with the
uh oh dude speaking of Wayne font just
you have to everybody has to the Barry
Sanders bye-bye Barry documentary on
Amazon Prime was one of the best NFL
documentaries I've seen heartfelt
touching it was
amazing you laughed you cried you
laughed you cried you you put on a pom
pom hat and you moved on why are the
Eagles plus three at home is Jaylen Herz
hurt is it Jaylen hurt what's going on
there Jake The Snake oh Paul God bless
you thank you Jake The Snake what's
going on in
Philadelphia
J no he's good to go um you know I think
there's a lot of 49ers love right now
because they blew out Seattle last week
and Eagles last been nail biters all
right you know what I'm going with the
Eagles plus three at home I don't give a
I believe in that lunatic that they
have as a coach
whoa all right he's getting three at
home the big thing went the 49ers Paul
you got to go up early then he can
expose that kid because other than that
he's just he's just keeping that Ferrari
on the
road I'm going to take for my second
pick oh I don't like PA doesn't like
this week guys I'm not going to lie um
I'm going to take I'm going to let the
train keep rolling with the with the
Denver Broncos getting three and a half
they they're playing the Texans I know
the Texans are good I know the Texans
are better but there's a little bit of a
a thing going on in Denver and I think
Shawn Payton's a good coach and I think
they writed the ship a littleit around I
don't know about that point five I
didn't like that point five we always
hate the point five the listen the point
five is AK the bites wait you're get
you're getting three and a half yeah oh
then I like it yeah no but I'm saying
the0 five is always the snake the bites
Paul I didn't think I liked it turns out
I like it I mean you know who am I who
am I Paul I'm just some jerk off picking
games I'm gonna take the Green
Bay Packers getting six against the four
the Kansas City Chiefs in Lambo because
you know what the Chiefs should kick the
out of them and that's why they're
not gonna because that's what the Chiefs
do okay and I know this time year they
start turning it on right Andy Reid
starts putting his belly on people going
like are you are you going to show me
You Got What It
Takes are you gonna feel the mustache on
your nose right and then they
they start playing but I I I think uh I
like that kid that kid's got a cannon
it's Lambo maybe it's snows Paul hey
ain't talking just in the parking lot
all right I mean everywhere okay talking
in the restroom right yeah that was the
reference the restroom uh
oh man the Dolphins line is too high
otherwise I would take them otherwise I
would take him but Paul's laying off
dude the Dolphins are the AFC East team
that I just don't know anything about no
I know I know still I just always get
excited because I think it's Nick croll
and then it's like NOP it's their coach
all right I'm gonna do something stupid
here I can't believe this everybody tell
Paul you got good head on your shoulders
don't do it come on you're doing so well
Jake I need you Jake Jake to snake this
is the best part of this year's show is
Jake just comes in Jake slides in like
the analyst he does but I'll tell you
Andrew Themis very quietly
killing it I'll tell you somebody else
who's a a beast Nate Craig Nate Craig
goes the Bears are a lock he said that
last night or whatever two nights ago
three nights ago football that's saying
a lot Jake uh how are your chargers
healthwise and are they mathematically
eliminated um great questions they're
not mathem Ally eliminated but they
might as well be they're they're nearing
the end and um
healthwise not not great um not great
either um but if Keenan plays that
that's that's the big injury to watch um
that's all right no further questions uh
paulse heard enough thank you no no no
Jake that's that's what I needed thank
you buddy all right no problem all he
want to know is that they were
healthy uh Jake I love Jake all right
you know what I'm gonna take
the I'm going to take the Atlanta
Falcons against the hapless New York
Jets I I I looked at that game I I just
don't know who Paul who are the Falcons
huh it's like some psycho check that
this thing one week I like it though I
like it they gotta win by a field goal
dude the Jets are on their third
quarterback they they're they're slowly
you know oh they bench that other kid
well yeah and you know them showing
Rogers in a red jersey practicing I mean
the guy had a kiles thing of
three months go man he's not it's it's
he's not playing so
um oh gotta I'll take that uh yeah I'm
taking a Falcons
man Falcons are a lock Jets have no
offense that's coming from themus
right yeah it's coming from thas oh okay
listen dude if a third string
quarterback beats that pick oh he tried
to help me he said San Fran is
healthy is the only thing people in San
Francisco hate more than the rent is
people who don't live there calling it
San
Fran it's Frisco that's how we you order
it cheese steak like this no one cares
oh themess said he's still taking the
eagles look at that okay um all right
I'm gonna take the Rams at home minus
three and a half against the who knows
what they're going to do Browns
I hate the 0 five but Paul you know what
I don't like myself either so I kind of
like that line it reminds me of
me I like that we got a new one from the
show the 0 five is a snake that keep the
snake that bites the snake that keeps on
biting um all right I like that I was
looking at the Rams Browns that's
another one that I just don't know this
week is hey Paul keep your eyes on your
on paper Okay this week is
wild
um you know what
dude I it's eight and a half eight and a
half how many picks do I have
left
it's oh that point five Paul takes out
your
knees dude the amount of walks that I
take because I don't flip out in front
of my kids I just take a walk my
neighbors got to think I'm crazy I don't
watch the games I watch my team play and
whatever Prime Time game is on and
that's it and then I look at I thought I
was the only one who did that know I
don't I went to I went to the car show
this week bill you know how I find out
how my picks win I look at the phone at
the end of the night and I watch my team
play and whatever Prime Time games are
on I don't this NFL package you
got to be out of your mind to buy that
if I'm looking at six screens like a
cat with a laser that
dude uh I'll tell you what I don't I
don't like that it's on YouTube
I don't either I just don't like and you
know what I don't like I don't like that
they made me get Direct TV and
then when they switch to YouTube they go
no and then they start going like oh no
dish hanging off the side of your house
it's like you didn't say
that 10 goddamn years ago did you I know
well did you all right I got my pick I
just saw you know about the NFL nobody
picks up the phone over
there they're screening my calls every
week when I
whine they no they see the number they
go dude don't get that one dude don't
get that don't get that one he's a
terrible Gambler and he's gonna blame us
again just funny he thinks it's
fixed there's literally 50 guys on both
Sidelines he thinks they're all
involved and they keep their mouth shut
that field goal miss is she's taking out
on you um I'm going to take this the
Pittsburgh Steelers every Andrew goes
he's asking about the prevent defense
again I I mean I can't I can't if if you
want if you want to take the call you
take the call what's he gonna do talk
about the flight gate again no there's a
phone line there's a phone for everyone
but then the bill bur phone is
red the red one's blinking dude it just
says do not answer on top red one's
blinking dude the red one's blink which
kicker missed what else is new they're
trying to find most these just called
Sunday night this jerk off's
calling us on a
Tuesday uh I'm gonna take the Pittsburgh
Steelers I'm GNA take the Pittsburgh
Steelers at home and the only Rhyme or
Reason for this is because Mike Tomlin
at home is just a winner the line is
under six so if they win the game by six
I get the game I don't really know what
the car Cardinals are doing I don't
think their coach is nearly as good as a
Steelers coach and the Steelers are home
that's my reasoning I always think
that's a good reason good coaching Paul
goes along way a good coach does good
parenting you know yeah quality
ingredients in your dish you know those
are the three things I I I'll stop there
you know and knowing what's important
knowing knowing what's important yes and
keeping your head covered dude the Bill
Burr hotline is the funniest the red
phone buzzing is my favorite part of
this
episode can't hear you Andrew we can't
hear you we can't hear you I was just
thinking how funny it would be in a few
years if like they had Ai and they just
had like a designated AI to handle the
bill burline so it's just this fake
person putting up all the talking points
they got like the NFL Red Zone but the
AI works so hard that they got to like
you know computers get hot servers they
got to like cool them
down so that they got to have a guy pour
water on it the bber AI but works so
hard when I call up customer service by
the end of it I get the guy to admit
that he's in India
I wear them down the thing is you don't
curse and you just keep saying that's
not acceptable and then they just they
just they're just on the line with you
it's like a NASA like NASA and Houston
like they're all in there and the guy
looking at and and before every field
goal they're just looking at the phone
like
this all right rock paper scissors to
see who's gonna have their Sunday
evening I don't like this I feel like
people don't like me um who who's next
or we done we got the Monday night
special brother wait did we pick four
each did you pick four Paul picked four
right you picked the Steelers that was
your last one we picked
okay all right so what what's the Monday
night
special win some money for you we did
hit one we hit one we came so goddamn
close to next week and D this past week
we we should we should we last
week our pick last week should have we
should have just been like you know I
take full responsibility no get it done
I told thess I like when we lose it like
that I don't like when we lose it by one
thing I like just being wrong early Paul
you're the most positive guy I've ever
met in my life well you know what hey if
I'm gonna fall down a flight of stairs I
want to hit every
stair if I don't have at least five
broken bones I I don't feel like I got
my money's worth I get to lay around my
wife makes me
soup positive pulie we got the
Cincinnati Bengals without Joe burrow
going into Jackson Ville against
Goldilocks oh yeah the the the
the the goodlooking zombie that's a
great one the good-looking zombies great
I don't know what to do that
guy's a
killer Trevor Noah and he looked Trevor
Lawrence he looked really good last week
dude he's a stud and they're on Prime
Time think it's a blowout dude that guy
could pick me up and the red phone that
they don't answer at the NFL and
throw me to the other side of the globe
I like that guy what's the spread eight
and a half
[Music]
dude if there's one more half
you Vegas you know it's
some little wormy prick out there and
he's got one of those little
pencils Paul look at me when I'm talking
to you he's got one of those little
pencils without the erasers
because he never makes a mistake Paul
yeah but you know keeps job you know how
he keeps his job
five it won't hurt you with
eight I'm G to tell you something that's
one of the things that I love about you
the level of confidence that you just
said that with it's like you already
watched the game no no no but it's a
point eight it it's it could be in the
benefit because of nine you know the
number wise Eight's rough when's the
last time you saw a team win by eight
you know whenever a guy is bundled up as
you is starts talking with his shoulders
I just I just shut down you're like you
make just I mean it's not gonna stupid
hoodie touching your hat no come
on man this is a nice soft one I'm not
saying it's not nice but the combination
of the two do you have on
mittens
Paul's wearing a onesie all right Paul
Paul's saying the eight and a half's not
gonna hurt
us uh who do I have to call at the NFL
to get rid of that fucking0
five we could take the Bengals if you
want to take I don't understand how you
think the0 five is not going to hurt us
you're looking at it like they're going
to go seven seven seven seven seven and
it's like not a factor oh Andrew says
yeah ATN to rush for a touchdown that's
a good one because they give him the
rock a lot all right what about Joe
[Music]
Mixon I don't know but you got to you
got to get down the field the thing
about this is ball the the Cincinnati
Bengals have a really good defense so I
think they're gonna hang with them for a
half and at that point Trevor Lawrence
how about good-looking Paul bunan how
about
that the brownie towel guy that
looks like he knows where the weed spot
is all right so Trevor law we're gonna
figure out a nickname that isn't that
long so how about this Trevor Lawrence
to throw one
ATN to rush
one and then what's the
third do you know what I kind of that
we've been laying off of go ahead I like
it I like it already I like it already I
didn't even say
anything
um you know we always go with the number
one receiver now these aren't great
teams right now because of in injuries
or anything just keep this in your head
Paul next
time there's a great defense playing a
great offense they're going to do the
bellich thing where they're going to
take away their number one option so
next time we bet on a receiver
we should probably go the number two
receiver kind of woke up to that with
the Kansas City game even though Kelsey
got one um that's just something to
think about Paul but not on this game I
just wanted to waste
time um Paul I'm not going to lie to you
I can't name one player on either not
one Joe Joe burrow Joe mix
Trevor
Lawrence uh Jamar Chase Kiki vanderway t
uh T
Higgins um well we don't have to pick
the game we can pick Lawrence to throw
one ATN to rush one and then what's the
over under the under over is the over
under is
39 everybody's gonna take the
overp everybody's going to take that
ball but what about you Paul Paul you're
different Paul you stand out from ah
that that that number is too good I
don't like
it I don't like it dude oh you like it
you like the under you want to be that
guy as the fans are walking out you
stand up on your
seat and said I took the under oh there
you go top of the stadium oh but that's
only no Andrew that's only one
point you could tease it up one
point you could tease to 43 you want to
do that and take the
under yes all right all right let's do
that or or the Jacksonville money
line what does the money line even mean
I've gambling it means Jacksonville just
needs to win you don't get as good of
odds what the odds on that right
you don't get the OD but but it's a part
of
it um I would tease it before I do the
money line I want people to make some
money here okay so let's do that let's
do Trevor Lawrence to throw one how was
my hand whiter than my head they're both
out in the same sun right no head gets
more exposed you got
pockets um
money it doesn't take it directly but
you think I'm walking around in my
pockets my hands in my
Pockets um you know I saw a guy one time
I was stopped at a red light and he was
standing with his hands in his pockets
and I wanted to yell out hey get your
hands out of your pockets get your hands
where I can see them just to see if he
would do it
[Laughter]
you know it'll be funny if he starts
taking like why the am I listen to
this bald
idiot um all right we could do that
that's perfect timing it's one o'clock
we're done let's do that we'll do ATN to
rush one Trevor Lawrence to throw one
and we will tease the under over up to
43 and we will take the
under and then um and then there you go
I think that's it just to give him some
odds to make some money how's that sound
themess Jake good
I like it oh he said money line is a
good fourth Ed edition if you want to
push
it I mean that just
means you want to push it Paul you want
because Jacksonville is gonna win the
game Jacksonville is gonna win a game
it's Monday night they're home I need
you to say it three times like
Beetlejuice for me to believe it
Jacksonville is gonna win the game okay
that's it it CH there's a chance it
might not move the odds much so we'll
like we would leave it off if it
actually what is this the Squad you guys
like call each other man it's like 60
degrees in here uh yeah we could take a
look at it but yeah that we can add that
in as a for if it does if it does
something for the odds let's just add it
on because we all think Jacksonville
anyway um all right guys that is the
show those are our picks for uh week
number Lucky 13 and um download the B
MGM app as always use bonus code bur B
RR uh deposit your $10 deposit and you
can get back
$1,500 back regardless of your first uh
regardless of the outcome of the first
wager so uh bet responsibly have some
fun this weekend enjoy don't take it out
on your wife enjoy the Christmas
music Have a Holly Jay missed
it spilling the eggnog chestnuts
roasting on an open fire what the
are they
doing Jack Frost nipping at your nose
night
holy night if he's not fired next week
I'm
done look at his face we gonna win with
that
guy uh all right everybody enjoy this
week's game Throw the
ball uh we'll see you next week uh take
care all right
byebye and